you're just like they're doing it they're doing
the things you want them to do and they're acting
too I care about that I want to keep watching
just like get to the next action scene I really
thought that we were gonna turn on the camera
for this movie that we were just gonna be like
it's fun go out of great action it's really cool
can't wait for the next one I was so surprised by
just how much of an epic crime fan at
like I would call Ray to a epic crime
drama I would call this an epic crime fantasy
what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation Greg and John we just saw a movie that
we were so back and forth on whether or not
we should go to the theaters and watch it
not because we weren't interested don't get me
wrong we saw the first three of this franchise in
the theaters we just know that with the channel
whatever this video is going to get in views it
would do phenomenally better if we just waited
on video on demand just did a reaction at home
but something was calling that we had to go see
this we couldn't let it go we did watch this in
IMAX and from the opening shot I went God you
know I never forgot the size and scale of IMAX
I forgot how effective if you get really great
sound design yeah and a beautifully shot movie
yeah yeah like yeah this is effective this is the
first John Wick movie I've seen in IMAX and every
time I'm gonna re-watch it it's going to be an
iMac so thank you IMAX for inviting us we've seen
other movies in IMAX that we have not recommended
but I'm going to tell you watch this movie in IMAX
it's two hour 40 something minute movie I could
say with the utmost confidence within the first
20 to 30 minutes of this film immediately was
like I am so glad I did not wait to watch this
on video on demand and on top of that too by
the time it ended I was especially glad I was
so happy you feel rewarded for the decision the
views don't matter John we should watch this in
the theaters what matters is life and bullets
yeah please go ahead leave a like like on this
video that would mean a lot just another heads up
John Coy and I we're gonna be having a panel at
one Recon this coming Sunday March 26th 11
o'clock A.M if you are in attendance would
love to have you come say hi let's talk about
John Wick chapter four I'm gonna try something
out here I'm gonna give my little percentage
rating at the top 95 why what's the missing five
well that's what engagement's for you wait around
and you find out what that five percent's all
about the last 30 seconds of this video so John
what is the plot oh my goodness well John Wick
he's still trying to clear his name and his debt
to the high table and they're still coming after
him but there's a new player a Marquee in the game
who is uh looking to wipe John out once and for
all and then a whole codery of other interesting
characters uh inter lope into the plot along the
way now for the longest time I have said to
myself that the first John Wick movie is still
my personal favorite is the most personal is the
most intimate it's and it's best structured in my
opinion and I really do like love the franchise as
a whole but the first one has always remained my
favorite one personally I agree this one though
I don't know if it's my favorite one I will say
that out of the sequels it is my favorite one of
them all I feel like I could really argue with
anyone on why this one is the best one yeah it's
the best one it is an easy slam dunk and it's not
just because of the action that's the crazy part
like yes okay look I don't want to give away a a
lot of these action scenes but there's such
a variety here that is of course impressive
why I was so hooked within the first 30 minutes
was because weirdly in that First Act you don't
spend a whole lot of time with John Wick in that
First Act instead as you see in the trailers you
got all these other characters now when you see a
trailer for this movie you go he's probably gonna
have like 20 minutes of screen time Donnie Anne's
probably gonna have like a cool scene or two they
have a whole new list of characters here and
I thought they were all great yeah they were
excellent characters Donnie Yen nine times out of
ten you take an international Superstar like that
guy you put them in some American Cinema action
film they go to waste they do not waste this guy
they let him have the kind of Donnie in action you
would want when you watch one of his films from
his country absolutely and he also provides a sort
of like Lucid style to go along with his character
who's blind but more importantly than that it's
a great performance he's intimidating scary funny
but she becomes so emotionally invested in him he
had lines in this movie that earned the biggest
Applause yeah absolutely and I mean you could just
tell he's so inhabited especially the role of a
blind character in a movie like this even that
didn't play as typical I feel like usually they
just have super powers and can sense everything
but the way he threw himself into really feeling
and creating the movement and the language of
this character on screen was something really
impressive to behold he really went all out this
movie to me it just had this great seamless blend
of anime Western uh neo-noir video game any
kind of action you've ever seen in your life
the movie's really long before watching it I was
kind of under the presumption that it would just
be over indulgent I thought it would just be
a movie where it's two hours and 40 minutes
of whatever action scene they could throw at the
screen and that's all it's really going to be this
movie allowed the scenes when there was an action
to truly breathe to truly have a mood it's truly
hone in and evoke stuff coming from within its
themes about existentialism literally the point
of life what is the purpose of this you know I
have asked myself this when watching the John
Wick film stuff why are you still doing this why
don't you just give it up and die and then themes
about fatherhood themes about friendship things
that Brotherhood things I was not expecting this
movie to do it's the most artistic one of them
all from behind the camera it really brought it
back to that really awesome cinematography that
I kind of missed from the first one but they did
something that felt literally like I was watching
a graphic novel come to life in so many ways yeah
and it also really inhabits and uses the palettes
of everywhere it goes in the world because this
is a very Globe trotting movie in Japan you're
in France you're in all sorts of places and each
one of them really feels immersive and like they
really thought about every possible way they could
use the features of these places to accentuate
the action but also to accentuate yeah the the
visual palette of the movie and there's a certain
Elegance I think coming out of the theater we were
talking about the raid and The Raid 2 and the sort
of jump between those movies and I think this has
a lot of that strained Elegance not that it's
necessarily only about the crime world because
we've seen it applied to there but it also just
has this desperation of Will and character and it
is like one of those movies that you don't expect
to come out of feeling like it is a fully fleshed
character journey and yet it does it is because
it's an ensemble piece their stories are equally
important in this whole journey that all centers
around John Wick because to me this movie's like
if The Raid 2 met the Fast and Furious Universe
in a way sure because of the physics of the human
body in here because yeah it does get a little
bit ridiculous of course how many High Falls can
he withstand not just him I love most all of these
people in this war yeah when you reach a certain
level of Hitman in this Society do you just get
overpowered or some kind of like body armor beyond
your suit but the movie is still very intense I
thought it was just gonna be popcorn fun you know
how the the third John Wick movie starts off with
this great 20 minutes in New York and I thought
that was going to be the movie but I noticed that
no one was even really applauding in the first 30
minutes we were just so engrossed by what was
going on with the story and the action had a
great intensity to it throughout and that's what
you want from this movie this sense of like real
personal stakes and finding myself on this journey
going are they actually gonna kill this guy off or
not yeah you know I mean you think that about John
you think that about multiple people and I think
this one and the first one I think make really
nice bookends because you have such a uh fruitful
blend of yes action and beautiful Cinema but also
an emotional core that really does feel vital like
the second and third movie love them both as well
but there is much more that's just motivated by
the lore and the World building and just the rules
that apply to everybody who's a Hitman that's all
there because you had the personal one with the
first one and then you got the Big World building
and the crazier hide in action in physics with the
human body and this kind of encompasses what the
previous three films did and kind of even better
at the same time too I gotta say too a guy who
I kind of whenever I hear is playing a bad guy
I kind of roll my eyes at now because I'm like
of course he's playing a bad guy oh he had it
he was effective he was great Bill Skarsgard he
plays a French man where several times during this
movie I would have one or two thoughts this guy's
the best villain out of the whole franchise
secondly I would have many times where I go
I love the philosophical questions that are
here in this movie hiroyoki Sonata he had
this wise man almost Ronin Shogun assassin-like
quality to him and here I've often joked about
how they always have to make him do sword fights
in movies in American Cinema I think this is his
best one sure no no no 100 I mean I'm sure that
this got to be I I would imagine he would have
even had input on it like it is very satisfying
and it doesn't distract you that way and there
are also multiple other weapons at plays I think
the world really sweeps you up into feeling like
yeah this is this is right for this scene
rather than just oh we got a mirror let's
do that and also shouts out to Arena sawyama
who who plays his daughter character because
she really threw down along with everybody
else to sell everything like during her
fight scenes as well and just her presence on
screen I thought she uh lent a beautiful sort
of warmth even though that's not how I would
describe like the characters necessarily to
the pursuit readings because so much of this has
to do with the real toll and cost of living this
life being a part of this world and the fact
that there's always some loose end that is
going to come back and come for karma essentially
yeah their story in this movie greatly affects
the trajectory of this entire Epic Journey
that you go on throughout this film foreign
Scott Atkins he's the one guy who you bring
over here and you're mainly like I just want
to see him have cool fights he has great
fights and as a fan of action Cinema to be
able to watch a movie where you got hirio
kusanata you got Donnie Yen you got Scott
Atkins in here and they really utilize them
it's like an action it's like a wet dream man
how come to the library just like they're doing
it they're doing the things you want them to do
and they're acting too I care about that I want
to keep watching just like get to the next action
scene I really thought that we were gonna turn
on the camera for this movie that we were just
gonna be like it's fun go out of great action
it's really cool can't wait for the next one
I was so surprised by just how much of an epic
crime fan at like I would call Ray to a epic crime
drama I would call it epic crime fantasy yeah 100
it still has that peripheral fun there is a lot
of latent humor that's not overt absolutely wants
you to chuckle and have a good time with it yeah
it's just got so much flavor and there's still
more to the world of the continental and the high
table and all that stuff and nothing it's like it
could easily become pretentious or become silly
and I think they find the perfect blend to prevent
that from happening and yeah I mean you mentioned
that fast and furious kind of physics but they
never uh go silly with the way they portray and
capture anything it always feels as grounded as
possible yeah and that so that sells the things
that feel a bit more out there they have these
great actions these have some great wonders in
there they do things that are like I can't how
do they keep topping themselves how do they keep
finding inventive ways that keep surprising me
uh at every turn of man this doesn't feel like
you're just pulling [__] from your previous
movies the action in this movie has such an an
amazing blend of a wide variety of styles from
swordplay to of course the gunfu as they call it
yeah the the nunchucks scene was with like they
really made a full-on John Wick nunchuck fights
which I've been waiting for in American Cinema for
so like no one hits themselves in the nuts it's
amazing and like you got shirukin throwing stars
you've got dogs horses pretty much anything you've
seen in a previous John Wick movie plus more new
kinds of fun yeah the car play my god there were
shots in here I was like I can't believe they're
doing this there's one that starts off with this
above shot wonder is all I'll say yes yeah if
you're looking down for a long time you'll know
it's one more time it's brilliant Ian McShane
gives another great performance once again
shouts out to Lance Reddick not in this film a lot
but when he's there it's very effective I really
appreciated him being here may he rest in peace
because yeah the second he shows up on screen
I'm like God damn it is a bummer not to have
this guy it really is also I I cannot remember
the actor's name but another sister his name's
Lawrence Fishman are you Sam Samuel Jackson no
no Lawrence Fishburne uh Lawrence Fishman Barry
King Brown Clancy Brown also great um but no no
the track guy who plays tracker no but there's a
character nobody I mean that's how I suppose his
name's nobody or just a Tracker he's great yeah
yeah he's great uh he is one of the best lines
in the movie makes for a really interesting wild
card yes and an interesting thematic compliment to
John the five percent that was kind of missing
for me there was maybe like 10 minutes in this
movie where I was going you can probably pick
it up a little bit but out of two hours and 40
minutes I'm like to have only 10 minutes of that
film where I'm going I'm kind of waiting for you
to get back to a little bit more of a rhythm
here a little bit more pulse I don't even know
if it's 10 minutes it might have been like five
where I had the thought go off in my head for a
second of speed up a little bit regardless I don't
even think when that scene was happening I would
want this movie to not have that scene I would
still prefer that scene being in there secondly
um yeah just a couple of questions that I
would occasionally have with this movie of
how's he flying to all these places I did
have that exact thought I was like who's this
airplane guy that seems like a real easy way to
get yourself caught it turned into that I'd say
it's a couple little nitpicks how's it going from
A to Z exactly because he's kind of globetrotting
you know John Wick's got a special tunnel that
goes under the Atlantic Ocean that's all yeah
you know screw him bumping it up 97 oh you're
almost at my rating yeah you're almost in my
rating what are you I'm a 98.5 G nice nice what's
that excuse me I have no idea I'm just leaving it
up there because I'm sure there's I got my 10
minutes we'll probably go away on my re-watch
that 1.5 is for anybody who comes up to me with
a point that I would go oh okay fair yeah it's
for the airplane thing that's what it's for but
guys I love the hell out of this movie terrific
um I can't wait to watch this two to three
more times watch it in IMAX because it's well
worth it it's amazing all right guys thank
you so much for being here and uh subscribe
leave a like I just want to come we'll
talk to you guys soon thank you foreign